Oh, hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Oh my god, it's been a very long day.
I started my day since... I started my day at like 10 in the morning.
And then I can't really say what I was doing.
Okay, so 10am, I had to give dad to the dog sitter.
Because I've... He was supposed to get a... He was supposed to get a check-up.
Re-check-up today.
But then the event rescheduled, Byron's already paid for the dog sitter.
So I was like, I'll just have you... Have him be taken care of by the dog sitter for a bit.
Just so I can relax.
By relaxing, I mean just so I can focus on work stuff.
So it started at 10 in the morning.
And then from... I can't say exactly what time.
But I can't say exactly what I was doing until tomorrow.
If that gives any indication as to what I was doing.
But it was related to the stream that's tomorrow.
Because obviously, you know, the game's technically not released yet.
So I can't say what I was doing.
And then... And then... So with Zen and Naimu.
And then... So I can't do a super long stream today.
Because right after today, I have to go back to what I was doing.
That's related to tomorrow.
So I'm... I'm a little tired.
And my hands hurt.
Not hurt.
But like... My hands are a little sore.
From holding a controller.
I...
It's... It's a little sore.
It's... So... So I... So that's all I can say really about it.
But I can't... Can't say much.
But like... Hint, Hint.
Um... Anyway...
Um... Dad update.
So...
Taking Dad to the dog park was a fucking mistake.
Like... Why you ask?
Well... He has learned... Dad has learned...
That when we are at a dog park...
The other... Owners... At the dog park...
He realizes that...
The other owners at the dog park...
Have treats on them.
So now...
All he does... Whenever I take him to the dog park...
And he sees...
People there.
All he does...
Is he goes up to the owners...
And just sits there.
And be like... Yes!
Do you wanna pet me?
I know you do.
Oh, you think these pets... Oh, the first one's free.
Oh, but I know you have a treat there.
Oh, now, don't you want to give me a treat, too?
Yes, he goes up to, like, random pet owners.
And he, like, begs them for treats.
And they'll be like, oh, I'll be like, I'm sorry.
Sorry.
He's already eaten.
He's just really food motivated.
I'm so sorry.
And then when they refuse to give him treats, he starts getting mad.
He starts, like, sitting there looking at them and barking at them.
He's like, I know you have treats, bitch.
And then, you know, they'll give, like, one or two treats.
And then he's like, more!
More!
I know you have an entire bag of them!
And he just barks at them.
He's like, yeah!
And then it sucks because, um...
Like, because I'm like, please, I just... I need you to poop, please.
I'm here because you pee... Like, he would pee instantly.
And then after he pees, he goes straight to, like...
He's like, don't hold out on me!
I know you have more!
And then he would, like, go... Like, instantly pees.
And then, like, he goes over to, like, some of the owners and be like, come on!
You wanna pet me?
Yeah, the first one's free.
Oh, you wanna pet me a second time?
No, no, no.
You gotta pay for that.
You gotta...
He's like...
He's sitting there, he's, like, looking up, he's like, yeah, you want a second pet?
No, no, you gotta pay for that.
You know, I can smell it on you.
And you know how, like, you can smell the treats on these owners, too?
I'm so embarrassed.
I look every...
It's, like, almost every day now.
It's...
Bell, welcome to Domino Fire!
Welcome, welcome!
Racksheet, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
On a scale of 1 to 10.
I'm so embarrassed.
Because I always have to, like, apologize.
I'd be like, I'm so sorry.
Like...
And then, like, one...
It's because, like...
It didn't get that bad.
But one lady...
Kept giving him more...
And more treats.
And then she gave him her entire bag...
Little baggie of treats.
And now he knows.
He knows...
He can break them.
Like...
Ever since...
That lady...
Gave him an entire bag...
Of doggy treats.
After he, like, broke him.
After she...
He, like, broke her.
He knows now.
He...
He knows.
He can...
He can break them.
He...
Beg the people for treats.
So, he'll just, like, shimmy around the person.
Until, like...
I could pick him up.
Like, it's so...
He knows, too.
He knows.
I'm like...
It's over.
Look.
Like...
Gotta pick you up now.
He's like...
No.
I can break him.
He's always two steps ahead of me.
Um...
But, yeah.
So, like, he...
Oh, my gosh.
He's, like, learned...
He's learned that they...
Like, 90% of the time...
They carry treats.
So, now he's like...
Oh, my God.
I don't know what to do.
I am...
Anyway.
That's the dad update for the day.
Um...
Oh, yeah.
By the way.
Uh...
So, um...
You guys saw that I...
To this week's member stream is...
Uh...
Roblox.
It's because during FanimeCon...
I got inspired by a dragoon...
That visited the meet and greet.
And he was like...
Yeah, I'm a Roblox developer.
Like, I make games on Roblox.
And I was like...
Oh, that's so cool.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
How much money do you make off of children?
And then he was like...
Six figures.
I'm like...
You know.
Very casually telling me he makes six figures off of kids.
So...
So, we're gonna...
We're gonna play some Roblox.
And we're gonna add...
We're gonna contribute to the dragoons.
While...
Maybe, guys.
I think it's time that I should make a Roblox game.
Guys.
Any dragoons want to develop a Roblox...
Dirty bird game...
With me.
Teach me your ways.
A Roblox goon.
Yeah.
The money stays in the system.
Anyway.
It's me.
I'm spending money.
I'm the one that that dragoon's milking off of.
Anyway.
Another little thing I want to talk about...
Is that...
Um...
Did you guys know that Last of Us Season 2 is out already?
I heard, like...
Nothing about it at all.
Like, on social media.
Which was crazy.
Because, like...
You know.
I feel like...
It'd be a bigger thing.
Since Last of Us Season 1 was...
Um...
Did so well.
And...
I was like...
I didn't hear anything about the second season.
Until, like...
One of my friends was telling me.
They're like...
Yeah, I'm watching the...
Season 2 of Last of Us now.
And I was like...
What?
It's out already?
I was like...
So confused.
Because I like...
Didn't...
Oh, so this...
This game is distracting me right now.
So I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna mute this.
Um...
But anyway.
So I was like...
What?
It's out already?
And then, like...
I...
You know...
Um...
I didn't hear anything about it.
But it's been...
It's been around for like...
It's been like...
Out for at least a month now.
And...
Okay.
Spoiler.
If you guys didn't realize...
Why everyone hated the second game.
Um...
Here's a big spoiler.
It's because they killed Joel...
Off...
Instantly.
And then, obviously...
That's gonna hap...
That hap...
That was gonna happen in...
Season 2.
Because it's based off of the second game.
Um...
So, like...
I got to like...
The second episode.
Like, I watched it.
Because I was like...
Curious.
Because my friends were telling me...
Like, yeah, season 2 is out.
And then...
Um...
It was like...
One of the biggest...
Dumb thing that they did.
Um...
And...
I was like...
I was so sad.
Because I really like Pedro Pascal.
So, they do it instantly, too.
So, I was so... I was so sad because I was like... No!
He's dead!
And then my... I can't believe him!
Why would you kill Pedro Pascal?!
No!
He's so hot!
And then... And I was telling my friend about it.
I was like, why?!
And then my friend was like, you know... You know, like, he's in... You'll find him in the Mandalorian, right?
He's, like, everywhere.
It's not like he's gone forever.
I was like, it's not the same!
He wears a helmet in Mandalorian!
It's not the same!
It's not... I wanna see his face!
It's not fair!
I thought you liked how it's... Yeah!
But, like, Pedro Pascal, though!
But, like, it's not the same!
There's something about, like, Joel Pedro Pascal that, like...
That, like, hits different!
I'm really sad!
Because I was like, no!
Why couldn't you kill him off in, like, episode 5?
I guess!
Why?
He'll be... Not the same!
He's wearing something... He's wearing, like, dorky outfits in Fantastic Four!
He's a fucking nerd in Fantastic Four, guys!
He's Reed Richards!
It's not the same!
I need, like, the Joel version of Pedro Pascal!
Um... Um...
Um...
Um... Defective, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thanks for coming out to Fatima!
It was a lot of fun playing trivia!
Can I get you that $90 as your lifeline in the end?
The liar!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, I want rugged Reed Richards!
I don't want, like, nerdy scientist Reed Richards!
I...
Anyway... Um... Anyway...
I don't know if I'll keep watching Last of Us Season 2 at the moment.
I don't know!
I don't know how I feel about it!
I did enjoy, um... The first one.
I just didn't quite... I don't know.
The first two episodes, it's like... It was just alright.
It was alright.
Um... Um... Lali, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
So MNK code, it physically hurts her to use a code!
No!
The reason why!
But, like, um...
I'm not gonna be playing MNK anymore on... on Elden Ring.
It's because I actually... my wrists start... started getting really sore.
Because when I'm, like, moving... I don't know why...
Because I'm using my wrists too much...
in Elden Ring.
So, like, right after I did the stream for Elden Ring...
my wrists actually got really sore.
So, like, I had to use controller.
But then, like, today, when I was practicing...
Sorry.
When I was doing what I was doing...
Doing what I was doing today...
My hands got, like, sore from holding it.
From holding the controller.
Look, we all might know what it is, but, like...
It's all hypothetical and assumptions, guys.
It's all assumptions.
Rogue, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The Last of Us series is a one time where...
a video game, a television, where it would have been justified to deviate from source material.
Joe got the...
HE DIDN'T!
I was like...
NOOOOO!
What?
What's the fucking point?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, also, like...
You know that Asian guy, um...
That's in The Last of Us?
I forgot his name already.
Like, Devin?
I don't fucking know.
I don't remember his name.
Evan?
I don't know.
I might not even say...
I don't even know if that's his name.
I might be making it up.
But, Jesse?
Is it...
I don't know.
Did I get all...
That got his names wrong?
Oh, no.
Devin's the...
The other...
That's the other women.
The Asian guy.
Um...
The only thing I know about that guy is that...
Apparently...
He had an insane League of Legends addiction.
Um...
Because, like...
I was watching his interview...
One of his interviews...
And he was saying that he used to...
He was, like, a gamer back then.
And he had a crippling addiction to League of Legends.
And then he had to, like...
He had to full on...
When he started getting bigger...
Became, like...
Got his big break...
He had to delete his League of Legends account.
And he was saying, like...
I spent thousands of dollars on that League account...
With so many skins and everything.
And I had to delete that account.
To pursue acting.
I was like, holy fuck, that is commitment.
They're like, well, why didn't you just, you know, change your password?
And he's like, you don't understand.
It was really bad.
It was... Like, no, you don't understand.
It was really, really bad.
Like, deleting the account was the only way out.
It was... And like, but yeah, like, when he got his big break, he literally was like, I can't, I can't, this will ruin it.
If I keep playing League, like, return to being human.
And he had, like, thousands of dollars of League skins, too.
Like, he was like, yeah, thousands of dollars of League skins.
And some were, like, super rare.
I can't get them anymore.
And, but then, like, it's all gone now.
It's all gone now.
Like, he had to destroy the curse with his own hand.
Literally, for the sake of his career.
Um, Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Use your phone for Rod Again Award.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, so yeah, I thought that was really interesting.
Um, but that's, that's basically it.
The life update and dad update.
Alright, Super Mario mod!
I wanted to play long today.
But like I said, I gotta do more stuff with Zen and Larmu later.
Because, okay, um, you guys, okay, I'm just gonna say.
If you guys didn't see, like, the teams for the event.
It's, like, pretty, like, like, we know we're not gonna, like, win anything.
But, like, we just want to make sure we know what we're doing.
Like, we just, we just, we just want to know what we're doing.
So, like, so, like, you know, like, at least we progress.
Like, like,
Tokyo time!
Alright, let me... Alright, here we go.
Where was I?
Oh, I was on Donkey Kong then.
Space, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll talk more about the details tomorrow on stream.
Thanks for doing the meet and greet for Fanime Sunday.
After the Saturn got cancelled, everyone in line was stoked and it was fun to talk to you about the Simpsons hit and run aftermath.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Stuff Shark, thank you for the magenta stupa.
Hey, Doki, today's my birthday.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course you can!
Thank you, my magenta stupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Stuff Shark.
Yeah!
Oh my god, I'll tell you guys about what happened at Fanime.
So, like, I talked to 40 plus dragoons on day one of Fanime.
And so, like, that was, like, I even went overtime.
So, like, I almost got to, like, two- I got to, like, almost three hours of just pure meet and greets.
So, obviously, apparently, right after, um, I saw on Twitter, people were saying that, like, there was actually, like, um, group- group B and- group 2 and group 3 that were turned away.
Anyway, um, yeah, like, most I've ever talked to was 30, um, because it's usually, like, two minutes, uh, per person for, like, an hour.
Like, two minute slots for an hour.
So, usually, I would do maximum 30, because even 30 is a lot for me, um, for, like, one session.
Um, so, the fact that I had two sets, like, I had, like, you know, day one and day two with meet and greets.
Um, so, I didn't realize that.
And then, um, right at- like, right after, you know, like, when I was on Twitter, I saw a lot of people were saying on Twitter, they're like, oh, yeah, I got turned away, we lined up and everything.
And I was like, what?
And then I told- asked my, uh, staff, I was like, what's going on?
And my- even my staff didn't know what's going on, because, like, I had one event staff that was at location, at the convention.
Um, and she was saying like, no, it's so differently.
They were saying that there's like all three groups went through.
So, um, so apparently what happened was that, um, it wasn't just me.
Um, but like they treated it like an autograph session.
Where you know how they're like, they autograph and then it's just an autograph and a photo.
And maybe like talk for like 10 to 15 seconds and then next person.
So they treated it like an autograph session where it happens like super duper fast.
But like that's different from a V2 or meet and greet.
Cause like, it wasn't just me, but apparently people were getting turned away for like other sessions as well.
Like other, um, meeting, like other autograph sessions.
So they did that.
Um, because they expect cancellations and stuff.
So they expect people to not show up because it's free.
Um, so they, since I was like their first VTuber guest, um, they didn't really know how the system worked for VTubers and like how, um, how like, you know, everybody will show up.
Like, they don't know that everybody will show up and then like, you know, and yeah, cause it was a free meet and greet.
Um, you just needed to have like, it was a lottery though.
Cause so people just had to, um, uh, uh, people were had to, had to like, you know, just had to sign up for the lottery.
So they picked like a hundred and, I think it was like, for the first session, they picked a hundred and, I think like 40 dragoons from the first session alone.
Um, and I wasn't aware of that.
And then like, um, and obviously all, like majority of people showed up because it's like, whoa.
Cause it was like three groups.
And so like, I heard about what happened and I heard that you guys lined up.
So like my staff and like family staff got together to be like, what the fuck happened?
You know?
And obviously they, now they know what to do.
Um, now they know like what to do.
So they, for the next VTuber guests, they won't overbook them stuff.
But to make up for it, I did two extra sessions.
Um, I did two extra sessions on Sunday, uh, for the meet and greet.
Um, so I had basically a nine to five on Sunday.
Cause I started my day at 10 a.m.
And then I ended my day at 5 p.m.
I...
Because, um, I had a meet and greet.
I did an artist alley.
And then I did an artist alley.
And then, um, um, and, um, and then right after the artist alley meeting the artist there, I went to my meet and greet, and there was supposed to be like one meet and greet.
And then, and then a panel.
And then I'm done.
But then I did the meet and greet, and then I did the panel.
And then I did the second session of meet and greet to meet everyone on Sunday.
That got cancelled on Saturday.
Unfortunately, that meant the people that applied for Sunday might not have been able to meet me.
Because at that point, I met 120 dragoons.
I met 120 dragoons in the span of two days.
And that's like my record.
Because I have never gone above 40 before.
I've never... So, I'm sorry I couldn't do more for Sunday.
Because at that point, I was so tired.
I was so tired at the end.
Yeah, I like tripled my record there.
But I do hope... I do hope everybody had a good time at Fanimate.
I had a great time meeting everybody.
I do love meeting my dragoons.
And I'm really sorry that happened at Fanimate.
But now, like, you know, they know what to do for VTuber meet and greets.
Like, you know, I'm the first one.
There had to be, like, mistakes going in.
It was all a learning experience for them.
And so, like, I hope that, like, lets them know what not to do next time when they get their next VTuber guest.
And I was just, like, you know, a learning experience for them to, like, improve how VTuber stuff is done and things.
But there were so many dragoons!
It was crazy.
It always makes me so happy to see so many dragoons show up during these conventions.
Aphelion, thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Space, thank you for the super chat.
The League icon speaks to me like the Green Goblin mask.
It's like they laced it with black magic or something.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They underestimated dedication of the dragoons.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
You need to treat dragoons better.
They are too starved for...
What do you mean?
My dragoons are so overweight for the amount I feed them!
You are just like that.
Even when I feed them, even when I feed him, he's out there trying to have more.
He's like, I'm so hungry.
We're not all chunky.
Guys, that's it.
I'm removing it.
That's it.
You say I need to treat dragoons better?
I'm taking down the last cup of coffee waiting room.
I'm taking it down.
Until you appreciate me.
What?
No!
Please!
That's right!
I'm gonna... I'll do it!
You know I will.
Take those dragoons down instead.
Puls, what have you done?
That's right.
Appreciate me right now.
I... I got those videos and I instantly uploaded them.
Richard, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
He's trying...
Oh!
You think I'm trying to scare you?
All right.
Look at that video right now and I'm gonna private it.
You want to play with me?
You want to try and...
She's gonna do it.
Powerball, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy to see you.
I'm being great.
It's almost a year since last time I met you at AFCON Anime Expo.
Thank you for the super chat, Powerball.
Thank you.
No worries.
It was great meeting you, too.
Oh my god.
You were like the last person on day one, too.
I don't... Oh my god.
It was great talking to you.
Manny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki is a kind and generous VTuber.
She loves us and does so much.
Dragoons, please stop angering her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lord Corozos, thank you for the super chat.
Words cannot express their gratitude.
You are the most gracious of the leaders.
Oh, thank you, guys.
Thank you.
All right, guys.
Now I'm satisfied.
Now...
You have... It's like...
You know, it's like those, like, angry gods that you have to make a sacrifice in a volcano.
And you have to send... You have to sacrifice, like, a virgin or something into a volcano.
And then, like, the gods have now been satisfied.
That's me.
That's me right now.
All right.
The VOD lives on another day.
Don't worry.
I shall not...
The VOD lives on another day.
We saved... You guys saved the music video.
That man with power now.
All right.
I don't remember...
I don't really remember...
Oh, yeah.
I remember now.
I think I talked to everybody here, right?
Oh, yeah.
That's where the cookie was.
I volunteered as a tribute.
Oh, Ninja.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
You can sing happy birthday to the stuff shark?
Of course I can.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear stuff shark.
Yeah.
Happy birthday.
Pasebo bunny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I show up, and the first thing I hear is the wonderful Doki threatening us.
What did you do, Dragoons?
Exactly, Dragoons.
What did you do?
Oh, yeah, I remember now.
They, like, fucking launched him out there.
Oh, oh, wait, I got healed.
Well, that was weird.
Was that your toe friend that just got shot out of the cannon?
If you like, I think I'm advice on how you can help him out.
What did I do?
You will just blast out whenever you want, be it supplies or even coins.
You should give it a shot to help your friends out.
No, that's fine.
Wait, is stream lagging for you guys?
Is it YouTube?
Um, is it YouTube?
I did, like, adjust some stuff.
Let me look at my output.
No, it's not the right.
Is that the usual?
Uh, Doki required appreciation and YouTube started dying.
It can... it can't handle it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Duck.
Um, but yeah, is it just my...
Is it just me or is it just you?
Is it just YouTube?
Okay.
Sometimes YouTube is weird.
So, like, I couldn't...
I don't know.
If it's just YouTube, then I'll just...
We'll just...
We can wait a little bit.
It's okay on my end?
Yeah.
Oh, YouTube is having issues.
Is any other channels having issues or is it just me?
Oh, it's happening to both streams?
Ah!
It's always a YouTube.
I think it's just bandwidth stuff.
YouTube is always bugging out in general.
Did I get everything here?
5-2 is supposed to be a place of history and nature.
I swear, we can't have nice things with a Koopa Troopa around.
Can I just go for it?
Well, too bad.
You can't fight us with a teammate.
It's against the rules.
Now, scram.
All right.
God damn it.
I have to use Toad.
Okay.
I found the TM.
All right.
Nice.
You gotta try Mega Man Legends.
Audio, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I'd like to go back to Mega Man.
Just one day.
Better not leave without Mario.
I better not leave without Mario!
Oh, it's here.
Oh.
Ah.
E.
Hey, you.
Let's have a battle.
All right.
It's time to fight him.
Most likely, I'm gonna try and finish...
I was gonna say Donkey Kong.
Most likely, I was trying to finish Donkey Kong 1.
And then...
After...
Donkey Kong...
I'm gonna stop at after finishing Donkey Kong World.
Just so I can have time for it later tonight.
So I don't get too tired.
Zekra, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I'm very grateful for being dragged out of that seamlessly endless health.
Which was when...
When it's in my turn for the meeting.
I cannot thank you enough for doing it.
All you can for us.
I have many more Dragoons.
I hope many more Dragoons get the opportunity.
I hope so, too.
It was...
I always love doing these meet and greets.
And just, like, you know...
Getting to meet everybody.
It's always a great time.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
That's why I do so many...
Oh my god.
They both use Protect.
That's why I do, like...
So many conventions.
Because, you know...
It's such a unique experience to meet Dragoons.
And it's always such a...
It's such a...
Like...
For some people, it's a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity.
So, like...
I always love doing the meet and greets.
Okay, we'll try to drop that guy.
I don't know if I can pick him up.
He's a pretty big man.
Big rock guy.
Okay, yeah.
Oh, I caught it!
Oh, not big enough!
Not...
That's right!
Not big enough!
Alright, get out of here.
Alright.
Nice.
Hammer, bro.
Alright, goodbye.
Oh, okay.
That doesn't matter.
It did nothing.
Alright.
Use our boomerang.
And then...
I don't know what to use.
I guess, like, payback?
Okay.
That's awkward.
It's awkward.
Okay.
Oh, no, guys.
I guess ice?
Maybe ice will work.
I don't know.
Kogashi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What's nice meeting you at Fandime?
I was the dude that asked the Three Kingdoms question.
Was it a fun highlight on the weekend?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad.
I had a great time.
Mavis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, please.
Mega Man Legends.
Only you can help us get him off the moon.
Please.
Okay.
I now have ice.
I'm just using payback.
Oh, okay.
There we go.
That works.
Oh, nice.
I should have used ice in the beginning.
I still don't remember...
I still don't remember my type advantages.
Yay!
It sucks, though.
I don't like...
I don't like this gimmick.
Because I fucking hate Captain Toad.
What is he doing here?
Make sure you have enough party when attacking.
Don't get caught off guard.
So make sure you have enough...
Wait, where am I supposed to take this rock?
Oh, here?
Is that a button?
I can't tell.
Alright.
Oh, okay, what did I do?
Yeah, but we got to put up with it.
Where's Bowser's orders and all?
Do you hear something?
I think it's coming from above us.
Oh no, Mario!
Wait, what about me?
Am I... Oh, I'm okay.
I was going to be like, oh my god, it's coming towards me!
Mario, look out!
I'm going to get isekai'd.
K-k-k, you don't want to take this ladder, do you?
Well, you have to get past me and let me warn you, I fight in a very tricky way.
You killed him.
K-k-k, you asked for it.
What?
I was going to be like, Mario, no!
He has his airpods on!
He can't hear it!
Alright.
Unnerved.
It's too... Okay, let's see.
I don't even remember any... I don't remember my moves.
It's been too long.
Wait, I have all fighting?
Okay, no, there's this fire.
I was going to be like, oh, that's awkward.
If everything is fighting.
Okay.
Wait, actually, what was it?
Is it heat crush?
Where is my weight?
Where is dad's weight?
Alright, dad.
My big boy.
That's right!
My big boy!
Time to crush him!
Okay, that's not it.
No retreat.
Come on, crush him!
That's right!
Sit on him!
I don't understand why... You guys ever heard that thing where it's a kink for...
Where people pay, like, hot women to sit on cakes?
I don't understand that.
Does anyone have... Does anyone want to, like, tell me why?
Yeah!
Have you guys heard about that?
Kink?
They pay, like, women to, like, sit on cakes.
And then, like, yeah, like, you... Is your... I don't know where I found out about that.
I... It's called... Wait, it's called cake fight!
What?
I failed.
Wait, what was the tricky thing?
K-k-k-k-k?
I gotta get out of here!
Wait, you said it'd be, like, really tricky.
What was the tricky part?
Um...
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, don't... A trunkle?
I don't have a trunkle.
I also forgot to fix my third monitor.
I know I was supposed to, but...
I forgot.
I forgot about it.
Okay, but how does he... Okay, whoever explained to me about, you know...
Wants to be a trunk... Okay, the guy that told me about...
Cake fart.
I'm trying to... I'm trying to find you right now.
Alright.
Oh, it was D-Dragon?!
No, oh wait, Gordon!
Alright, Gordon, you also knew.
Wait, I know about this.
It's Cap.
A large rock that becomes a grass type somehow.
When a piece of it breaks off, it gets its own mind.
But the Cap committee banned this power.
Alright, you get to be a trunkle.
Yeah, you look like a guy that enjoyed sitting on cakes.
Yeah.
Yeah, that looks like a tree that...
That wants to sit on a cake right now.
Wait.
Gordon.
Goon.
Oh wait.
Uh...
B-b-b-b-b-b.
There we go.
That's what...
Wait.
Defecto.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Papa Smurf.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Seeing how you went above and beyond.
For the group 2 and 3 goons.
Just prove why you're my Kamioshi.
Also glad you like your rare fish.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats, Gordon!
We know what you like.
Like...
I know...
Wait.
Actually...
Now that I...
We know.
We all know.
That's why you get to be in the exclusive goon cave.
Is there a...
Is there a Mario mod that looks like a cake?
You know what?
Uh...
Yeah.
It's almost like a cake.
Don't put him.
When I find another one that looks like a cake...
I'll...
I'll replace him.
Uh...
Yeah.
You know, we...
We got one of the parts in there.
Uh...
Cafe Clone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Again, for Fanny being able to dress as two Doughkeeper outfits...
And interacting with fellow Dracos was such a blast!
Uh...
Fuzzy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Boo!
Gotcha!
Nutmeg.
What's a nutmeg?
Oh, that's his name!
Oh my god!
You haven't!
I can't believe you...
You named...
How dare you!
You're just a minion!
Who named...
Who gave you...
Who gave you the...
Uh...
Audacity to name yourself?
Who gave you the right...
Alright.
Rock for that fucker.
He did not protect.
Wait, what?
That's it?
Okay.
Oh, I used the wrong one.
He was supposed to sit on him.
God dammit!
No!
My money!
Did anyone get the license plates on that bird?
Uh...
I'll just use that.
Alright.
Come on, dad.
It's time to sit on it.
Okay, guys.
Who wants the super chat dad to sit on...
Who wants the super chat dad to sit on this bird?
Come on!
Any tickets?
Any offers?
Toki, please...
Do not sit on the bird.
It's too late.
He sat on the bird.
That'll be five dollars.
Alright.
How...
Uh...
Sorry, Toki.
This is not my kink.
Daxi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Sit on that bird.
Okay.
Now, who wants the...
Who wants the super chat to watch dad sit on the bully?
It comes with a complimentary kink.
Sit on that bird, dad.
Red mage and whoop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sit on that bird, dad.
I paid good money for this.
Oh my god!
It's not...
Guys, who would have thought...
Something made of metal...
Who would have thought...
Something made of metal was not...
Cannot be squished.
Oh, man.
That's...
Butters a little squashed now.
Uh, eating.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Nice.
Don't do it.
It has horns.
My surprise attack wasn't enough?
I mean...
I literally talked to you, so it wasn't that surprising.
I had to talk to you.
Oh, look.
There's an ookiki.
Already got one.
For these, so we can ignore it.
Alright.
Okay, we gotta talk to him.
Stop!
This is my item.
You will not lay your rubby hands on it.
Alright.
I'm gonna touch it.
It's time!
Say it!
Tokia!
I'm gonna sit on that eye.
Alright!
In front of a live audience!
Say it!
Say the line, Tokia!
Uh, Tom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm gonna squish it!
Uh, yeah.
It is.
This game is free.
Google Super Mario mod.
Stop!
Toki!
This is a sitting stream now.
Alright.
Nice.
What the fuck?
He dug a hole?
That's just a mummy!
Okay, we gotta...
Okay, we're gonna...
Oh, but I can't do anything.
Okay, I'm just gonna do this for now.
And I'm gonna swap.
Did I learn...
Doki is...
No, no, no!
Dad is obsessed with sitting on things.
That's different.
That's...
Are you kink-shaming Dad now?
This is a kink-shame-free zone.
Alright.
Oh, it doesn't...
God damn it.
I thought I was gonna...
I thought like...
Um...
My...
Uh...
I thought Dad was faster.
Now lick it too.
Okay.
We're gonna have to wait for him to come back up.
You're gonna lick it too.
Oh, it doesn't affect him?
No!
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe it!
It doesn't affect him!
To the victor goes the spoils.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, safety goggles.
I wonder what that does.
Guess I'll never find out.
I'm gonna have a Fudgy.
I don't need it.
Schooling.
Wait, actually...
I can just level up.
Right now if I kill it.
Bye, Fuzzy.
Goodbye!
Yay!
I'm gonna blow my nose.
I'm not gonna mute myself for this.
I'm too tired.
Alright.
Yay!
Level up!
Wait.
A toad wants to fight me?
I thought we're on the same side.
Solid Snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Toki, please.
Whenever you bring this stuff, I'm gonna get trauma flashback from when I was a content mod.
Your imagination gives me nightmares.
Check out all the rare creatures I found up here!
I thought you were on my side.
Why are you fighting me?
Oh, he literally just caught all of these guys.
Okay.
Alright, that's...
That's neat.
Alright, let's get...
Oh my god.
This is the perfect one.
It's actually...
Guys, look what happens to Rex.
Look what happens.
If he lives.
It could've...
It would...
Oh, there we go.
Look at...
That's right.
No!
Sat perfect.
That's what I want my cake to look like.
Okay, we just need to hope that dad doesn't die.
Yay!
Alright.
Sick bug grew to level 31.
Oh nice!
He flinched too.
That's what I needed.
Yeah, I need a...
Fuck, I only have fighting too.
That's bad.
Because like, a bird doesn't care about fighting.
No more.
I used it all up, guys.
My content!
How would dad make a living now, chat?
Guys, this was his 9 to 5.
Now he's gonna be...
Now he's gonna be homeless.
He lost all the peepee.
How would he make a living now, chat?
What will we do now?
This was...
This was his real job.
This was how he's gonna...
This was how he paid half of his rent.
Now I have to kick him out.
Alright.
We need a...
Only dad.
Absolutely, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh wait, it hit himself.
Nice.
Alright, and then we'll just headbutt...
Wiggler.
Oh my god, he's gonna make himself even angrier.
Oh my god, he's gonna go beyond...
Beyond the anger threshold.
What, you think he lives here for free?
Why do you think he's been sitting on cake?
It was definitely not a hobby for him.
It...
Alright, we gotta...
We gotta send...
We gotta swap Dragoon.
He might...
He might be fucked.
Don't worry.
Dad's a strong boy.
Uproot?
Oh, I'm gonna...
I can smash the...
Oh, I'm gonna smash the...
I'm gonna kill the Dragoon with...
With a...
Karate chop.
Friendly fire.
Okay.
Oh, never mind.
I guess not.
He lives another day.
Okay.
Oh wait, the move always hits critical.
I forgot.
Why me?
Oh, it's not very effective.
Good.
Stupid sandstorm.
Okay, good.
It hits him too.
Wait, what?
What happened to me?
Why did I...
Why did I like...
Swap?
That's Jala.
I'm gonna try it.
Again?
Wait, how many times can he do that?
God damn it.
Oh no.
Goodbye.
Goodbye Husky.
Fire upgrades.
Oh, fire upgrades at low health.
God damn it.
My only up...
You can't use it forever.
I'm gonna kill you.
You can't hide behind.
You can't hide behind the doll forever.
Alright, nice.
How is it still...
Okay, I was gonna say.
How is it still like...
Storming?
Those wasted crits.
It's okay.
This move always lands crits.
So it's not wasted.
Oh my god.
That's all he knows how to do.
He just knows how...
He just fucking...
Does a sandstorm.
Alright.
Yay!
I hope catching these are doing better than...
Doesn't violate any protection laws.
Alright.
I'll find a place to heal.
Has to be like...
Oh my god.
It's still stuff.
I wonder like...
If there's any water mons here.
Any water ones?
Oh god.
Never mind.
I just get stick bugged.
Silly me.
Silly...
Silly me for thinking...
I would ever encounter something else.
I'm so silly.
I just...
I'm sitting on this.
I...
Oh my god.
I can't even...
I...
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
Get out of here.
Silly me for thinking...
That...
It'd be something different.
You just get stick bugged.
I...
That's my secret.
I always get stick bugged.
I like heal from here.
Polio party.
Okay.
Wait.
Heal me.
Are you serious?
Oh!
Do I have...
Did I use my one-up on him?
Was that my one-up?
There's no way.
Or was that the...
Was that my one-up on him?
Is it taken out of...
My bag?
My one-up!
I had...
Stupid...
Fucking toad!
Stupid toad!
Oh my god!
I found out.
Okay.
We gotta heal dad.
Guys.
We gotta heal him.
He's not doing okay.
Guys.
We gotta heal him.
Okay.
I still have...
I still have this.
Alright.
You are gonna...
You'll play a big part...
In this world.
I know I have.
Oh no.
Oh.
I have a stroom.
Alright.
Goodbye, Hefli.
Thank you for your service.
I use...
I healed the wrong one.
I...
I don't know.
Okay, Hefli.
I guess...
Thank...
God, thank dad for your service.
Okay.
Attack that steals.
Alright.
Let's see.
Water...
Let's just get rid of water gun.
I thought...
I thought I gave it to dad.
Alright.
Nevermind.
Welcome back.
Welcome back, Hefli.
Alright.
Surely I live here, right?
Okay, I believe.
I'm gonna slash sumo bro.
That should be super effective.
Because it's a fighting.
Yeah.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
He, like, picked up the shroom and just ate it.
Okay, he's worked up.
That's good!
He still hasn't used his attack!
That's good, guys!
We're gonna make it!
Alright, big damage!
Big damage!
Big money!
Yay!
We survived!
Alright!
Let's heal ourselves real quick.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Okay, guys.
We gotta go back home.
Oh, it's uproot!
Alright, let's get uproot real quick.
Just throw a baseball cap at it.
Me and my 99 balls.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's fine.
We have, like, 98 now.
He's not gonna do anything.
Look at him.
That's fine.
I have more to try.
Okay, maybe... Okay, I'm gonna damage him.
Yeah, I'm gonna go hit him once.
Oh, shit!
Alright, let's get Stickbug in here.
Actually, no.
Husky.
So we can stuns for him.
Let's Topsy-Turvy.
Alright, let's stuns for this.
Oh, wait.
Is it not?
Oh, it doesn't affect him.
Alright, we draw locking.
I know it's, like, dark.
Put me in when you get him.
He's handsome.
Wait, what?
What the fuck is that?
He's, like...
He took off his clothes.
He's naked now.
Oh, my God.
He's naked.
He's, like...
He's, like, now look at me.
Oh, my God.
Kaz is a flasher.
Good creep.
He's naked.
What does he want from me?
Alright, crunch.
Maybe crunch will work.
Crunch on him.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yeah, that's why you wanted to be him.
He lulled me into the false sense of security.
And then took off his jacket.
Rusk, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can't be uprooted.
He looks like me for real.
The red eyes for not sleeping.
Yep, that's...
And the nakedness?
And...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
He's actually so hard.
Why is he so hard to fucking capture?
Oh, my God.
I don't want to kill him, too.
Because he already wasted so much of my resources.
I'll send a stick bug.
All right.
Uh...
I'll bite.
Jesus.
That's not good.
What the fuck?
What?
What is funny?
Okay, um, guys, I... No, it wasn't even weak!
It was just average!
There wasn't no, it's super effective, they didn't even say that!
Oh my god.
Stick bug!
Why are you useless?
Why are you... Yes, but I don't wanna kill him!
I don't wanna kill him!
I'm trying not to kill him!
Oh my god, I have nothing!
I don't even... I don't even know what half of his moves are!
I haven't seen... I haven't seen you in so long!
Alright.
Oh my god, what are your... What are your attacks?
That's it, let's get Hefty in there.
Stick bug is literally just, like, there to look pretty.
It's nothing else.
We're not parasoning him!
He'll die!
Oh my god, I'm just gonna kill him!
I swear to god, if this kills him, I swear to god, this is, like, my least... I swear to god... Oh, thank god.
It doesn't matter.
Hahaha!
All my other three moves are too strong!
No, I... I feel like Slash is just gonna kill him.
Oh my god, who... You know what?
I'm not surprised.
The scariest thing to ever encounter is a... is a naked person.
In public.
That's the scariest.
Cause there's like... They're like, no fear.
Hahaha!
It's like, no fear at all.
How?
What?
Alright.
They're really... Yeah, streakers are really fast, too.
How is he, like, the hard... I swear...
I bought... I took a loan for these balls.
I...
I... I took a loan for these... For these caps!
I am not using majority of my caps on this fucking uproot!
on this naked man!
I fought the... How?
Alright.
Oh, this is not looking so good, guys.
Please.
I went into debt!
I have loaned sharks on me.
Why?
Oh my god!
No!
It's gonna pass!
Rice!
Don't do this to me, Rice!
Don't!
Rice!
I used some!
Please!
Oh, thank god!
Oh!
Oh my god!
It was a...
Hot out!
Oh, thank god!
Oh!
Everything's okay.
I mean, everything is okay.
Rice just wanted to add, like, more tension to this fight.
Oh my god!
I got an actual move now.
Thank a fucking god!
Alright.
There we go.
Just for this fucker.
Alright.
An onion that can stretch its root to reach high platforms.
It wears its pot as a helmet to defend itself from attack.
It is a natural gymnast.
Alright.
What was it?
Was it Kaz?
He hasn't been named yet, right, guys?
I already...
We named so many goons that I've lost track on who hasn't been named.
Alright.
No, I'm putting you somewhere else.
No, you were actual hell.
I'm putting you somewhere else.
Alright.
Oh, I don't have enough.
Oh, wait.
I have a better name, actually.
I have a better name.
I'll be right back getting milk.
Don't worry.
I'll come back for you.
I'm just getting some milk real quick.
I'll be right back.
Just getting milk real quick.
Alright, let's go.
No, no, no, no.
I haven't gotten yet.
I'm getting milk.
He never came back.
I don't believe it.
How many...
Okay, I need to know how many caps did I use for that one guy.
I have to know.
I took a loan for this.
I took a loan.
I mean, chased by loan sharks.
Not right now.
Paroplank needs to learn his lesson, so leave me alone.
Hey!
Just where do you think you're going, huh?
At least I tried to talk to this like a normal person before just walking past us.
I did!
And then you were like, get out of here.
And I was like, okay.
The absent parenting is why I picked up streaking.
I was craving attention.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's important to make sure you have large enough party when tackling the jungle kingdom.
No, I can't go off guard, but I call it small battles.
So make sure you have enough party members.
Hey, you.
I can't let you pass.
Lord Bowser's orders.
Although, to be honest, the pay I've been getting, lady, hasn't been that good.
It doesn't help that a purple coin economy recently crashed.
Oops, guys.
I started the second depression in Wario Land.
Tell you what.
You helped reimburse me for my loss, and I'll let you through.
It doesn't merely fight.
Nope.
Sorry, then.
You gotta turn back.
Wait, what?
I don't have 5,000 quads.
I'm broke.
What?
I hate him.
I hate Captain Toad.
I hate him so much.
Now he borrows $5,000 from me?
Hey!
These wild battles are sins for me and my strategy.
I hate Captain Toad.
Why did I save him?
I should have let him die.
Why did I save this bucket?
Oh, yeah?
You were saying the sandstorm?
Now I'm gonna make it sunny.
Alright, I'll pick him up.
Okay, never mind.
I should have let...
I should have let him die out there in the...
On the clouds.
Remember when he was just trapped on the clouds?
When he needed my help?
I should have just let him die.
The sunlight is strong.
Okay, now I can use fireball.
And now I'll pick him up.
I'm gonna pick up a tornado.
How bad can it be?
Yay!
Is this Captain Toad game even good?
That's right.
Pick him up!
That's fucking right!
Now drop him.
It's a fun puzzle game.
Never played it later.
I really wanna play, what's it called?
The Yoshi's Yarn World.
That was really fun.
I actually bought like the amiibos for it.
Alright, take him up!
I thought they were really cute.
Wait, did the fireball not work?
I wasn't paying attention.
Alright,
we'll use the normal one.
It's where...
It's where they're like yarn...
Yarn Yoshi's.
Yay!
I'm the 132.
Am I supposed to...
Okay, I'm gonna go down so I can grab items.
Or yellow shell.
And then...
Ultra Syrup.
That's right.
I'll...
Hey!
Stop!
In the name of Lord Bowser!
Alright.
Tough Puff and Paratrooper.
Okay, I don't know.
Maybe ice?
I think ice would work against them.
Alright, pick up that cloud!
Pick him up!
That's right!
Up you go!
That's right.
Take him to the edge!
Where the sky meets the space!
Oh, of course you fucking use protect.
Oh, nice!
It did a lot.
Oh, of course.
Of course they did it on my fucking guy.
Wait, did I transform?
Wait, I didn't transform!
What the fuck?
You had one job!
You just...
All you have to do is turn!
Oh, it neutralized!
Oh!
Oh, that's okay.
I still killed him.
That's fine.
I should have killed him soon.
I should have killed the gas sooner.
Useless!
Useless cloud!
I need it anyway.
Yeah, I got lucky four hit.
Also, it doesn't even matter if my guy...
If the hammer bro levels up.
Because, like...
He's not even that important.
Like, he's not even part of my team.
Ah!
There's something nice about fixing these waters!
Despite their harshness!
Oh, okay.
There we go.
What's that?
A toad?
Oh, man.
This is gonna be a cinch.
Alpharet said this was the buggiest part.
Oh, okay.
I'm not surprised because there's like two mechanics to it.
What would be good against this?
I assume...
I'll assume ice again.
All right, pick him up!
Yes!
Pick him up!
That's right!
Keep picking him up.
I don't know what the snooze orb is from.
What game is snooze orb is from?
Okay, ice toss.
Oh, that did nothing.
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, that also did nothing.
Oh!
Whoops!
Wait, what?
He's ice?!
Oh, shit!
Okay, it's rain time!
I didn't realize...
Guys, I didn't realize he was ice.
Who would have thought blue means ice, guys?
Who would have thought?
Whoops!
Ice, ice, ice, baby.
Okay, it's okay.
Now I'm water.
Well, he is blue.
Wait, I should be using sunny day.
Fuck!
Why did I just...
Sorry, I...
Wrong one.
Oh, it still works!
Nice, alright.
Nice, it's alright.
I still killed him.
I still got it.
I still...
Yay!
Never punished!
Let's go!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
This is bad.
Alright, sunny day.
Actually, no, it shouldn't be fine, right?
No, it should be fine.
Alright, pick him up, too!
Yay!
Blunt Force Trauma with a boomerang.
Aww!
Maybe I should use...
Yeah, I think you're right, guys.
I think I should use...
I should have used fire.
It's okay.
Sunny day.
Sure things will be okay now, right?
Okay.
Never punish!
Let's go!
Oh, there you got it.
Okay.
Never punish!
Let's go!
Praise the sun!
Okay, now it should be okay.
Okay.
I chose, like, all the wrong elements.
Which I've noticed.
I literally chose...
There were, like...
It was, like, three choices...
And I already fucked up the first...
And I chose the...
The wrong one.
Twice.
Never punish!
Let's go!
Yay!
Hey!
Just where you think you're going, huh?
I'll just try to talk to normal to us.
Looks like...
Kara Blanc and Goomp.
Can we call Mario over?
What?
A Toad?
Do you need something from us?
Goomp!
Lock in!
We're surrounded!
Gah!
Mario.
How dare you take advantage of our petty arguments.
We'll take care of you once and for all now.
All right.
So, Toad is gonna die soon.
Toad does not look so good.
But it's okay.
I know Toad's just gonna use...
Just gonna change the weather non-stop.
I didn't know how to patch my game.
Apparently, the new patch makes it so...
Anyway, before I say it, I'm gonna squish some Goombas.
The new patch makes it so that he doesn't only use weather moves.
But like...
I did not know how to do it.
I...
I don't know how to patch games.
So, I'm just like, oh well.
All right, that should like, fully crush him.
Yeah.
All right.
Now it's time to see if...
Uh...
Nope.
Okay.
Oh my god.
This Hammer Pro knows more than one attack move?
That's the life.
I wish Toad also knows more than one attack move.
You patched the game to a new base rom, I think.
Yeah, okay.
I...
Yeah, that's too much.
That's too much, guys.
I'm too stupid to do that.
I'm just...
I'm just here to game.
I'm not here to patch stuff.
If I can't patch something with one click of a button, then like...
I'm hopeless.
One click only.
That's my motto.
It's so real.
If it's not streamlined, then I can't do it.
Because I'm scared.
He's the king of...
He's a big boy.
He's the king of all bombs.
That's right.
We gotta feed him more.
Give him more food.
He hungers.
He's so hungry.
King Dad.
You'll pay for this.
Oh my god.
We did it, Mario!
We're finally reunited!
It was a bit scary, I can't lie.
But I knew we managed to get through it together.
Now, onwards to the gone capital!
Okay, I do not want to be Mario.
I do not want to be Toad.
All right.
Where do I have to go?
I don't even remember.
Oh, I don't remember now.
Wait, there's...
Wait, what?
Oh, it's a statue of him.
I was like...
What the fuck?
Wait, he's right there.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I have to walk...
I have to hold your hand over too?
Jesus Christ, you're useless!
Why did they give you your own game?
Okay, and now I just need to talk to him.
All right.
Here we go.
It's visitors?
Nice to meet you.
I love super...
Oh my god, is this a super...
Okay.
My boy has a really tough time putting out advice and doing anything.
Like taking a shower.
But I thought I bought him a new game that teaches him how to take a shower.
But can I get to play a disc on a cartridge device?
None of it makes sense to me.
That move is more useful to you than him.
Yes, he loves Mario Bros 3.
They all love Mario Bros 3.
That's the secret.
What the fuck is that?
This is my seat.
I was at 12 hours before the show starts.
Don't challenge me.
I've always pitched for a slime poetry night.
It keeps getting rejected.
But I tell him it's not about slapping cards to the ground.
This is where Cranky on did his famous banana hack.
No one could stay in their seats.
Oh wait, is this a show?
Just a lot of courage to come up on stage and perform.
Just being here makes me so nervous.
Oh, is this like a comedy club?
Oh, it's a little comedy club.
Okay.
What's over here?
Cranky Kong performs comedy every night at Jay Apes.
Oh, this has a big crowd.
So I want to see what the big deal is.
Oh my...
I heard like...
Hey, Nintendo...
Hasn't added like, um...
Super Mario Odyssey characters to their newer games yet.
And people are mad.
I saw like a Twitter post about it.
How people were like...
Sad that Mario Odyssey characters are like...
Not...
Are like, uh...
Being ignored.
Army!
Today we stand on the...
Precipice...
Precipice of greatness.
What?
On the verge of seizing the ultimate prize.
The golden banana.
One so tame.
Those stinky apes will have to turn their sights at me.
My presence will be demanded.
So rally my Koopa Troopas.
Rally my Koombas.
Rally to the call of Bowser.
Charge!
Mamma...
Mamma Mia!
I thought it was me.
Until I saw Captain Toad.
Yes.
So inspirational.
I'm gonna cry.
Hello.
Hello, I can speak mushroom fish.
Good.
I live Kong Capital.
Hi, Mario!
I'm gonna get a really special break.
Record all of them.
I'm not gonna read this.
Not important.
Oh, I should save.
You're right.
I'll save real quick.
How many stars are there, anyway, in Super Mario mod?
Ho-ha-ho!
Gotta save it!
It's customer to gift a call in their first cart once they learn how to crawl.
Why learn how to walk when you can drive?
That is so true.
I say as I learn how to drive and never drove again.
Road work ahead.
Oh, sorry.
I went...
I went toad for some reason.
Road work ahead.
Yeah, I sure hope it does.
What's this?
Oh, is this a shop?
Hop, step, jump, jump, pool.
That's craftery.
Yeah, yeah, woo!
Magical spell is E-E-Poo.
See?
Nothing!
Wait, what game is that from?
All right, let's see what I can buy.
Okay, none of these work.
New to the con capital?
Well, there's plenty to do here.
Not that I would know.
It's actually my first time outside in a while.
Working for Bowser is cool and all.
Wait, will you look at this house?
I'm set to settle here now.
Monkeys?
Oh, we're not easy.
Listen!
I'm not going...
Oh, wait.
Did he swear at us?
Captain Toad did not want to translate that.
What did he say, Captain Toad?
What did he say?
Wait, what's the way?
Now, let's get my picture taken.
Why is he so far?
Wait, I can't even swim over there.
Finally, I can understand what everyone is saying thanks to this translator.
Makes some really handy adventures, doesn't he?
Wait.
I didn't even have to use...
Captain Toad didn't even have to be here.
Oh, it's the Safari Zone!
Wait.
What kind of cool mods are in the Safari Zone?
Oh, no.
I have to get rid of him if I...
Guys.
If I beat this level, does he leave me alone?
I need to know.
Does he leave me alone?
When I beat Conland?
Donkey Conland?
Okay.
Thank God.
I'm leaving.
I'm fucking getting out of here.
Alright, we'll come back to Safari Zone later.
I cannot deal with...
With Toad.
We'll come back later without you.
Want to see the castle?
Wow!
I want to challenge it, but I can't swim up waterfalls.
Wait, I can either.
Okay, goodbye.
Wait, I can't swim up either.
Wait.
I need to progress there?!
Oh, man.
Oh, jeez.
I hate you.
And I get stick bug too.
Oh, he yields me.
Yay!
Yippee!
I don't have enough energy.
Oh!
Look at the Jabby!
Alright, let's catch Jabby real quick.
Guys.
I'm gonna catch Jabby and I'm gonna call it here.
I'm actually so tired.
I think if I didn't have this...
Okay, I spent...
I'll say that...
I was there for a very long time.
I'll just say that.
I was there for a while.
That's why I'm like...
Yeah, I didn't think it would be...
I'll say...
It was a long time.
If I didn't have to go in there for that long...
I'd have more energy.
I did.
I...
I had like...
Um...
Actually, um...
It got something to eat before...
Uh...
Before the stream.
I didn't think there was like...
So much prep work going in.
I'm like...
Doing it for free, too.
I mean, I guess...
I get like early access.
So...
But I was like...
I didn't expect like...
The prep was like...
So much.
I got early access.
No!
Let me catch you!
That Jabby is strong.
I don't want...
I can't...
I'm worried I'll kill it.
That's why I don't want to...
I don't want to do any damage to it.
Because like...
That's definitely gonna kill it.
For sure.
Like, he's too strong.
Oh my god.
Please.
Hammer, bro.
Let me catch you!
Yeah.
I'll talk more about it tomorrow.
Oh my god.
He's dead.
I swear to god.
Trash goon.
If you kill him.
I swear to god.
Goodbye, dad.
Rush!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
If I catch Jabby...
Why is that so strong?
Rush.
If I manage to catch Jabby...
I'll name you after Jabby.
All right.
It's time to lick him.
Okay.
That did nothing.
I can't.
I was only able to bring out three of my Mario Mons.
I could.
If I could, I would.
He brought three of them.
Because Captain Toad took off the majority of my other Mons spaces.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is not looking so good.
I think I'm gonna die to a singular Jabby.
I...
One singular Jabby.
Oh my god.
Oh thank god.
I can't use anything.
It's gonna...
Okay.
I'm gonna try a Magnet Bomb.
Oh.
That was close.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
Please.
One fly versus a hundred goons.
You're one HP.
Are you still fighting for your life?
I don't understand.
Oh my god.
How is he so strong?
I have to use heal.
I can't let this one singular Jabby kill everything.
I actually have to heal.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's my strongest.
You don't understand.
The baseball cap.
I...
I took a loan for these caps.
The little bug that could...
How is he...
So strong.
Who voided my Jab...
My wild run.
All right.
Who was it?
Bro, that guy was like...
That guy was on all sorts of drugs.
Oh my god.
The rare catch.
Holy shit.
A large mature mosquito.
Its body grows stubby hairs that allows it to enhance sense of touch.
Is known to be very territorial and even wage tiny wars.
He is like EV trained in the wild.
Okay.
All right.
Can someone...
Who was...
Can someone type the name again?
Because I don't have the record.
Uh...
R-O-S-C-H.
Okay.
R-O-S...
Super chat...
Like...
Scrored up.
And I...
And I gotta make sure.
All right.
Rosh, boon.
You are too strong.
All right.
I'm gonna save it here.
Ah, this is a really short stream, guys.
I'm sorry.
This is a really short stream.
I am very exhausted from the...
Today.
I'm very exhausted from today.
And...
And having to...
To do the stuff that I have to do tomorrow.
But...
I did have a lot of fun, though.
Hanging out with you guys.
And I hope you guys still had fun with me.
Even though it was a really short stream today.
Um...
I really wanted to play longer.
Like, finish Donkey Kong Land.
But, like, my eyes are actually...
Like, drooping down.
Like, my eyes are actually, like...
Really tired.
So, that's when I knew I had to call it.
But...
I'm like...
And then, like...
I still have to...
I still have to do more stuff with...
Lai Mu and Zentraya, too.
Um...
After this stream.
So, that's why I was like...
Oh, I'm gonna be so dead.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
But I'll explain more...
About why tomorrow.
But anyway, guys.
Um...
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Oh...
Oh my god.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that...
Sorry, I forgot my outro for a second.
Because, like...
That's how eepy I am.
Um...
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Wait.
Say hydrated.
Posture.
Get up and move around to get that blood flow.
And you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
We'll be right back.